[Musique]
après plusieurs annulations de train et
de retard dans les transports entre les
mois de septembre et de décembre 2022
les détenteurs du Pass Navigo vont
pouvoir être indemnisés demain mardi 14
mars
Île-de-France mobilité ouvrira sa
plateforme de remboursement pour les
usagers des transports en commun les
indemnités seront comprises entre 37
euros 60 et 75 euros 20 la plateforme de
remboursement est ouverte pour une durée
d'un mois deux ans après le lancement du
vsq7 développé par l'Université de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines le CNRS et la
Sorbonne université c'est au tour de
l'inspire 7 de rejoindre les étoiles Le
nano-satellite dédié à l'observation de
la Terre et du soleil sera lancée le 3
avril prochain depuis sa base américaine
de Vanderberg en Californie les
principaux objectifs mesurait le bilan
radiatif de la Terre embarqué de
nouveaux équipements technologiques et
former des étudiants dans des métiers de
l'ingénierie spatiale dimanche 12 mars
la maison de vente aux enchères au zona
à Versailles à céder un document unique
une lettre de Robespierre à Danton
écrite le 15 février 1793 dans cette
lettre Robespierre y exprime son soutien
envers son ami Danton qui venait de
perdre son épouse décédé le 10 février
la lettre a été adjugée au prix de
218750 € et à partir désormais un
collectionneur parisien samedi 11 mars
la clé des champs de la ville de Plaisir
organisé une soirée 100% électro des
grands noms de la scène internationale
et DJ loco était à l'affiche elisa do
Brasil surnommée reine de la drum and
bass en France Arnaud Rebotini venu
faire découvrir les morceaux de son
dernier EPI ou encore les artistes
régionaux double troubles beyox deep et
flayou l'association Mani badminton a
organisé ce samedi un tournoi de
blackminton activité dont le but est de
jouer au badminton dans le noir seuls
les lignes volant et filet étaient
fluorescents pour permettre aux joueurs
de voir leur jeu
[Musique]